so to move towards sewer towards the sea
area I want to start just with some
basic intuitions for the way that I
think about this medium the way I think
about a meaning and how its conveyed
more generally so start with it with a
kind of challenging the question for you
which is uh so what does this sign mean
yeah so someone said woman here alright
someone said I saw a sign like that not
too long ago alright so yeah so it's not
it's not controversial you know for many
people but the question is how do we
make sense of this particular sign and
so of course we're drawing upon some
particular worldview and drawing some
kind of specific concepts from that
worldview that's being integrated with
the sensory mental image and so what I
mean by that is we have a meant a mental
image of what the science could
represent we have the sensory image
that's right there in front of us and we
immediately understand that sign as
meaning something like a woman or
referring so the fact that but this is a
place that women can be now you might
say well we don't all necessarily share
the same the same worldview but
something interesting that happens here
is that even if you don't believe that
women do or should wear clothes like
this necessarily it's not the fact that
you couldn't immediately apprehend the
meaning of the sign now this sign
however is another sign that's actually
developed at Indian Institute of
Technology used in hospital systems in
India that means the exact same thing
right so you have a similar kind of
process that the meaning and what I'm
calling a phantasm for reasons that will
become clear it happens in the same way
and this is a this is another sign
that's used in Oman right so we have
another sign here and so the idea is
that in fact when we begin to look at
this sign from multiple worldviews some
of the biases and the and the intrinsic
beliefs the built into the original one
begin to be revealed because you didn't
say to yourself was and that's what I'm
calling a phantasm because in fact it's
a kind of semi visible execution of a
worldview through the sensory mental
image that were encountering out there
in the wild so to speak because you
could have thought that this is somebody
wearing a kilt
this is somebody wearing a Kate like a
pride something like this
in fact interestingly you know I wrote
this book here back what came out in
but there's actually been an ad campaign
that's alright taking advantage of this
idea yeah recently like it was never
addressed yes so it's nice to see these
ideas out there no and this is exactly
the meaning and the other idea is that
also phantasms exists that encode
worldview but we can also develop
phantasms that are new ones that are
kind of empowering phantasm so some of
the some of the power of the
computational system interested in is
that revealing phantasms also creating
new phantasms and developing critical
awareness about them now in terms of
computing of course rely upon the same
kind of ideas right so an image like
this somebody being represented on and
as a Nintendo Emmy character and up
through images like this a kind of more
robust representation or an image like
like this these come from well-known
final fantasy role-playing games out of
Japan and one of the issues that I'm
interested in though is the fact that
these kind of phantasms then persist as
people begin to use these systems and we
know a lot about the kind of values that
go away that's that that lie behind
these kind of systems yeah so this is a
classic study by Kenneth and Mamie
Clarke you know start from the 40s in
which African Americans school children
were asked their famously which doll
looks like you which doll you prefer
which doll is a good doll and with a
high degree of probability you know that
they actually chose this doll that you
see the kids choosing choosing here
sometimes they ask what it all looks
nice with all it is a good dog then
which is all looks like you and there
are a few children that rebelled
actually I ran out of the study you're
crying when they realize the fact that
you know there a message within this
kind of worldview yes so this and the
point here isn't just to recap the study
which is the kind of well known study
but in the book one of the things that I
do is begin to think how can we look at
these phantasms in a semi-structured way
that's useful for thinking about
computing systems and so this is just a
kind of cursory breakdown just thinking
in terms of the types of elements the
attributes and so forth just
show that we think about these issues on
the computer we actually have to think
about them in a way that they're
instantiated in data structures and the
way that they're that they're
implemented when you begin to have this
stall immediately apprehended as being
the nice-looking doll
[Music]